المثيرة جدل يتعين على المرء ان
يقدم طلبا رسميا للحكومة اما
والسؤال الان اين هو هذا المصحف
اليوم? وبكم يقدر ثمنه? اليوم
الجدال فيما بينهم. وتمثل الجدل
حينها بعض الشيوخ والرموز
في السعودية فقد اصيب الناس
بالدهشة والاشمئزاز من جريمة
سيناء مستشفى عائلة الرئيس. في
بعض الاحيان كان عباس ينتظر عدة
وعندما كان يزوره والده الرئيس
صدام جلا في خاطره ان يكتب اشهر
الرئيس. وكان ذلك بمثابة نذر منه
فداء لنجاة ابنه الاكبر من
على السير. تم نقل عدي للعلاج
بمستشفى ابن سيناء في بغداد.
مشهد دمع تسبب لعدي باصابات
بالغة اثرت فيما بعد على قدرته
ولماذا كتب بالدماء فللقصة بقية.
في الثاني عشر من ديسمبر عام الف
المدينة وطرف ثالث سري من اجل
القاء نظرة على نسخة القرآن
في كتابة صدام للمصحف بدمه
تشريفا لصدام وقربة له عند ربه?
لترا من دمه خلال مدة قصيرة وهو
النذر الذي بر به صدام وخاف ان
يخلفه. لماذا يفعل صدام كل هذا
هو اغرب نسخة للقرآن الكريم في
العالم. كاد خطط المصحف ان يفقد
بصره. وقبل ذاك كاد صدام ان يفقد
رد بفتوى تحرم كتابة القرآن
الكريم فهل الدم نجس حقا? ام ان
القرآن الكريم بالدم الى شيخ
الازهر الاسبق جاد الحق علي الذي
صدام بالاعتداء على القرآن
الكريم حتى قولهم. في حين ارسل
وخمسة كانت تريد التخلص من كل
اثار صدام الا انه تم الاحتفاظ
واضاف في كل مرة كان ينتهي
مخزوني من دم صدام كنت اطلب
هو السر الوحيد الذي جعل صدام
حسين يعطي اكثر من سبعة وعشرين
المزيد وكان الحراس يقومون انذاك
بجلب قمع عليه ملصق مستشفى ابن
الدم كثيفا جدا ولم اتمكن من
العمل به. نصحني صديق يعمل في
يقبع القرآن في قبض مقفل بثلاثة
ابواب تحت مبنى ملحق بمسجد ام
نسخ القرآن الكريم واكثرها جدلا.
الا وهي كتابة القرآن كاملا بدم
وتسعمائة وستة وتسعين. وفي احد
احياء بغداد الراقية مر عدي صدام
العديد من المواطنين وقتها
استفسارات عن مدى حرمة كتابة
الجسم? وعندما يتبرع الناس بالدم
هل يتبرعون بنجاسة? نرجو وضع
ام انه كان عملا يدعو للاشمئزاز?
هل يصبح الدم نجسا عندما يخرج من
القرى مفاتيح تلك الابواب تم
توزيعها بين الشيخ ومفوض شرطة
العرب حينها اغتاظوا من صدام
فجاءت الفتوى على اهوائهم.
عليها فيكمل عباس عمله. يقول
الخطاط لم يكن الامر سهلا. كان
ثمنه فيقدر بملايين الدولارات.
انتم متابعينا ما رأيكم? هل كان
المصحف واحتفظ بها. ورغم ان
الحكومة العراقية عام الفين
بهذا المصحف في النهاية. الجدل
الديني ونجاسة الدم. بعد ان اوفى
حسين الابن الاكبر للرئيس الراحل
بسيارته الفارهة. وبعد دقائق عدة
ايام او حتى اسابيع بان صدام
حسين كان مشغولا ولانه كانت هناك
تهديدات امريكية. خلال غزو
العراق عام الفين وثلاثة حدثت
السلب والنهب والشغب حينها اخذ
الشيخ احمد السامي الرائي نسخة
اسبوع انتهى عباس من عمل نموذج
صفحة لتوافق اللجنة المخصصة
الموت. هناك امر صدام حسين امهر
الخطاطين العراقيين فجيء له
الاسلامية استنكروا ذلك وقالوا
ان كتابة القرآن بالدم حرام. اما
صدام حسين بنذري وكتب القرآن
بدمه اثار ذلك حفظة الناس واشعل
مؤتمر بخفضه بقطرات من مركب
زودني به. ويشبه وقد نجح ذلك.
بعباس شاكر الجودي وتم اعطاء
عباس قارورة تحمل دم صدام. وبعد
انهمر وابل من الرصاص من
بندقيتين اليتين على السيارة في
الجسدي وحيد المتبقي من صدام
شخصيا لمعرفة ماهية هذا المصحف
نجله. ما كل هذه الغرابة في هذا
المصحف? اوليس هذا هو الاثر
اجابتكم في التعليقات.